how's it going pretty good  you do any swing dancing no I don't have  rhythm no rhythm I know I'm a bad black  person I don't have it look like I could  sing but I can we never met with work no  is our first time I like you oh I'm a  nice person I'm sorry I'm sweaty  it's okay so where do you live we live  in New York I live in ill oh you're in  LA yeah it's the worst  you don't like watching us go I don't  like driving I don't like hiking I don't  like people happy too much Sun  everyone's just like women they flake  out on you really sorry at the beach I  saw a turtle can't come over does it  Lily doesn't make sense knows everything  says that I can't get over I saw a  turtle cancel the plans he was a slow as  you'd imagine